hey guys today it is December the third
my name is Jess McDonald and here
watching games for knees Bethesda has
confirmed that another doom alpha will
be taking place beginning tonight the
Alpha begins at 7pm PT tonight and will
run up until sunday december six at 859
pnp take much like the previous alpha
this is only open to a select group who
pre-ordered Wolfenstein the new order
and signed up for access you can check
to see if you're eligible by looking for
the Alpha in your ps4 or stained library
while xbox one owners should check their
Xbox Live messages if you purchased a
physical copy you can check out the
process for getting into the Alpha on
gamespot at this stage the Alpha only
contains a single map one game mode and
seven weapons EA has admitted that star
wars battlefront was designed to be
accessible and as a result may not have
had the depths that hardcore players for
after at the recent Nasdaq investor
conference in Europe I a CFO Blake
Juergen ssin explain star wars
battlefront is a first-person shooter
but it is one of the only team rated
first-person shooters we had designed it
to be a much more accessible product to
a wider age group for the hardcore it
may not have had the depth that they
wanted in the game elsewhere during the
presentation yogen ssin said he expects
battlefront to be a huge hit this year
particularly when it can capitalize on
the release of star wars the force
awakens he said he's confident that the
game will ship is target of 13 million
copies finally after telling us they
were not going to talk about the NX
console this yet Nintendo did have
something to say about it in a recent
time interview new nintendo president
tatsumi kimishima explained i can assure
you we're not to building the next
version of way over you it's something
quite unique and different it's
something where we have to move away
from those platforms in order to make it
something that will appeal to our
consumer base he added that it's
difficult to convince consumers to
switch from their current platform to
the next platform and that as far as he
knows there is no meaning
hina code name and X although he did add
perhaps mr. Awad meant to tell me and
Ben never got the chance let me know
down in the comments how interested you
are in nintendo's and X you can enter
gamespot we've got stories on uncharted
wars multiplayer beta and a full up for
beta pc patch that is everything I've
got for you today but do join the same
time tomorrow for the biggest stories of
the entire week I will catch you then